sponsored by step finance your go
to d5 portfolio manager on solana
luna if you're just getting into
bitcoin it's the perfect place to start
hey guys and welcome back to the lehigh pan show
we have another really exciting episode today
talking all about bitcoin as always this show is
powered by the vc firm icon plus capital and it
is sponsored by blockfi if you're interested
in um joining block 5 you can get around 200
i think they offer really amazing interest rates
much better than what you're getting um in the
fiat system right now so let's jump into this um
discussion today joining me is congressman pete
sessions from the 17th congressional district
of texas let's welcome congressman sessions to
the show how are you doing i'm good i made it
thank you very much what an interesting time
that we live in and especially for bitcoin yeah
absolutely it's so fascinating to see um more
and more politicians people from the traditional
system getting involved um and really just you
know sharing their um their support for bitcoin
so i want to go through all of this with you but
before we do um you mentioned it as an interesting
time and it certainly is an interesting time so
politically things are a little bit
polarized i'd say more so than ever
um i want to just sort of get your thoughts
in the general situation you know from
racism to covert to vaccines to now impending wars
there's just so much um polarization so i'd like
to get your thoughts um on the current political
landscape in the u.s particularly when it comes
to the federal government well the federal
government is engaged in an experiment that they
failed to at least the the majority party failed
to let people know what they would be doing
and we had a clear idea about donald trump
economically more people were working in the
history of the country more revenue was coming
into the federal government we were working to
finish off the wall in on the southern border uh
our military was moving uh towards a different
direction we had taken care of the problem in
korea north korea things were generally but
good but i will tell you that donald trump loves
a fight and so he had a fight with the american
people and uh we now see that we have a president
uh who despite his previous uh 29 or 30 years in
the united states senate he has done a reverse
course from what had been his past and from
the day that he began the campaign he was very
cautious and quiet did not give a lot of answers
day one he was in the white house he started on a
different pathway that pathway which has created
that further division this in this country
is uh based on inflation and availability of
jobs and covet and rules and regulations so i am
engaged in as a member of congress a lot of debate
that takes place about rule of law uh the border
uh people coming here afghanistan i mean if
you're if you're a policy guy you've got a lot of
stuff on your plate and and the bottom line is is
that what brings us to bitcoin which i think is a
fair once again my analysis uh bitcoin has become
very popular uh because we're trying to turn
the dollar into something that is less than
than something that would be strong and stable
and and be prepared for the future so many young
people have looked up in the last couple years now
i know bitcoin you know a lot of money was made
10 years ago moving forward but
increasingly the popularity is
that people who are younger than i am between
you and me in our ages they want to be able to
know that the work that they do and the
money that they save and the stability
of financial transactions is in their own personal
best interest and that's what the blockchain is
that's what cryptocurrency represents that's
what bitcoin is it is a an opportunity for you
to invest for you to have this safety and the
security of the of the transactions that will
take place that you can control much of it your
own destiny and so uh i've got a 35 year old son
who's a medical doctor he wants to be
successful in life 15 20 30 years from now
i have uh at my age i've lived off the
stock market i've lived with investment
and people who are younger need that same
opportunity last lastly the bottom line is
the stability of the currency in a world
market is coming increasingly under pressure
and that world market means that there are others
that want to overtake the dollar they do not want
the dollar to be the dominant uh currency and so
this new bitcoin this new cryptocurrency this new
way to look at life is uh is one chain across
the whole world uh and very interesting i think
has a bright future i as a member of congress
want people to know that we need to study and
understand this as members of congress i sit
on the house financial services committee
one of the senior members of that committee i get
in the debates i see uh what the fed is doing to
the dollar i want to see what regulation would do
what is proper regulation how should we look at uh
cryptocurrency and to make sure that america and
americans become world leaders and the stability
of the united states right with that so that
it makes america look good we'd like all the
money in the world to flow to the united states
but i'd say texas and the last part is uh that
riot blockchain is owns a the largest bit
mining bitcoin mining operation in north america
just about 60 miles south and east of waco texas
where i sit right now so a lot of interesting
things not just about uh blockchain and bitcoin
but about cryptocurrency uh from the high side
so clearly um a lot of appreciation for the
industry which i like and you mentioned a lot
of things that like education and regulation
inflation and you know the the issue with the
dollar and we're going to get into all of that but
before we do um something which is particularly
interesting about texas which i'd love to get your
take on is the exodus that we're seeing from these
democrat states like california like new york
i think even elon musk made that comment that
you know he's moving down i think he's already
moved down to texas i think it's tesla um that
moved their headquarters down to texas so um why
do you think there's this massive exodus to these
more conservative republican states like florida
and like texas and also what does that then mean
um for i guess the landscape in the u.s do you
have any concerns about this exodus towards texas
well the the concern is is maybe uh misplaced
uh and i and i do want to address that we you've
had the the the problems are in california
in these other states california's lost 151
billionaires of of recent and many of
them have moved to either colorado arizona
las vegas nevada or to texas and florida they have
sought these places at least to texas and florida
from a perspective of their less tax states
they do not want to take you know a death
tax they don't want to take your money california
chases people down five years after they have left
they're after desperately money and is
because they have an insatiable appetite from
their uh government to give things away to create
uh problems uh out of other people's wealth
and it's easy to spend money that is not yours
when it's your money and you're trying to be
judicious and careful and balanced about it
you tend to be a little bit i'm going to use your
term more conservative well yeah we do and i i
think that is true but we're also not here to take
your money so it's a freedom issue and freedom
is just as important as any of these terms
uh as opposed to conservative freedom means
that you will have a chance to come and make
your own mark to make your own money we want
you to take care of communities and organizations
and other people we're not like we don't care but
it's yours it's a fundamentally a freedom issue
and then i find that the people who are engaged in
in the last three weeks i've spent a good bit of
time at bitcoin type uh conferences and meetings
very benevolent people people who care very
deeply not only about others but about the future
and so i i would not offer nothing but
accolades for the type of social responsibility
caring about others i have a down syndrome son
i care about disabled people i care about people
who cannot take care of themselves but that
doesn't mean that we give away the necessarily
the riches or the savings or the opportunity
from other people but rather to build them
into uh the the the the enterprise system that we
believe in and and i think that's that's a great
thing so fear no freedom yes i agree with you on
that freedom absolutely i'm actually from london
and i'm i'm moving to miami for freedom purposes
so there you go it was either that or or central
texas i could not tell for sure that accent yeah
yeah definitely definitely having to move to miami
but let's go into bitcoin um because you know you
obviously shed a lot of appreciation for it um i
want to understand firstly actually how you first
came across it and what your initial thoughts were
the uh initial thoughts that i have go
back uh easily ten years where i began
talking about it and people looked at me with
strange tones and strange looks and of course
as you know some of the people that were the
first into the business have done very well
but i think that over time the stability
and the growth factor and the opportunity
for people to own and keep what is
theirs they don't mind paying taxes well
they know they have to but but they
they want to make sure that it's not
uh given away and democrats uh and this is just
the fact our our democrat our democrats love to
spend money your money they love to take away
your freedoms and they're a very expensive group
of people they have been expensive ever since i've
known them my whole life they like to take other
people's money and then throw epithets at you
about you to to take advantage of you what we need
is an opportunity and so i came across this to
pay attention to pay attention and listen and see
it has led me not only here in milam county
texas rockdale texas maybe a term that you
know uh where the largest bitcoin mining
operation is in north america but also to the
attributes of the blockchain the attributes
of this new technology the attributes of
confidence that young people have that they want
a bright future also and so every bit of that has
piqued my interest and i want us to be successful
as i've said i would like um anybody that wants to
have their business or job here in america will
take that money and do great things with it
you mentioned that democrats like to spend other
people's money and i understand that um and ted
cruz actually made a speech um a couple of months
ago saying how um politicizing bitcoin saying that
the left don't like it because they can't control
it now this had two reactions within the community
the first reaction was wow you know we have this
senator um you know talking about bitcoin that's
amazing however the second reaction was that they
didn't appreciate that it was being politicized
um and there's a there's a comment and a narrative
that bitcoin is in fact apolitical so i'd like to
get your take on that do you think bitcoin um is a
political and with that in mind do you think it's
going to eventually become a partisan issue these
are all very interesting questions and in fact i
have seen as you suggest crowds of people i've
been in houston i've been in miami i have seen
people who probably are a political who also don't
want it politicized just as much as i would say
the socialist in the crowd but the the unavoidable
facts of the case the factors and facts are that
the democratic party wants the money they want
to take what is there which means that they want
to invest time into rules and regulations
that will create barriers uh and hurdles
for them that will make it harder for the investor
to put the money in to make money and to take it
out uh and right now there is an opportunity in
washington d.c as we look at what we're doing
and you can kind of see the facts and factors
as they play without regard to politics
treasury department does not want
anyone to be able to get an ira
off of their uh what might be bitcoin bitcoin if
it's going to take off again needs more people
who will buy into the system and right now some of
our larger brokerage firms and some of these other
uh political entities that are called democrats
they tend to err on the side of them other
issues that are germane but that may or may not
be truthful and one of them is the energy industry
and you have seen where sierra club
in their calculations have stated that
uh it will be bitcoin uh it will be mining it will
be cryptocurrency uh because the mining operations
that would use excess excessive amounts of
energy electrical energy well there's some
balance to that because a good number of people
who are now in the bitcoin industry are getting
into green energy they're trying to feed what
might be the grid system with green electricity
that came comes directly from their money that
they invested to be a part of it so i think that
there are some things that are givens that our
friends that are democrats do want to pay for
the government they want to take other people's
money but we're trying to keep it into a territory
uh that is as you suggest a political yeah i
think you're right it is this it's going to
be an inevitable politic politicization if i can
put it that way of bitcoin unfortunately despite
the technology being apolitical um naturally
that's gonna happen when it comes down to
um you know empowering people to take ownership
over their over their freedom and their assets
you mentioned um regulation there and um you
know we've seen a lot of hostility um from the
the government when it comes to bitcoin um so the
question is what is the concern that america gets
left behind when it comes to this innovation i say
this today actually particularly because australia
have confirmed the bitcoin um spot etf but america
still doesn't have one canada has one but america
still doesn't have one so what are the dangers of
america being left behind and how likely is that
well i think i think left behind is perhaps an
appropriate term but i think what what might be
uh really a way to look at it is we would
be delayed or we would miss the market entry
the uh entrepreneur is the person we typically
have these sayings in the free enterprise systems
about ipos initial uh product offering and ipo
in many ipos in our history some fail but a good
number also make a good bit of money because their
value then became becomes seen uh by the public
and universally then the the power
related to their proximity to making money
rises the the the amount of wealth and
so i think it's important that ideas
like ipos be owned by americans that we put our
entrepreneurial hat on am i opposed to england
no do i want to see england make it heck yes
especially given their recent history with need to
be in an economy that is growing and strong but
not being british i don't want to tell the british
what to do but i do want to tell americans we need
to be smart we need to use our entrepreneurial
ability that we have we need to create the goods
and services we need to be able to create the
best ideas and that is what i want america to
achieve in this whole effort and then i want
the government not to crush it you know they're
good at killing the killing the baby in the in the
crib and uh we had this same issue as we dealt
with the internet how were we going to do it
were we going to tax the internet and at some
point it became big enough where we said okay
it can stand on its own two feet and america has
prospered but so has the system and that's where
the knowledge of the free enterprise system
the knowledge of this uh bitcoin uh blockchain
uh the opportunity we need to own that because
there are many many many opportunities behind that
for people to enrich themselves and
our great nation yeah you make an
interesting point actually about england um
obviously i'm from there and their lack of
innovation when it comes to crypto um compared to
miami's innovation um because they obviously have
a mayor who's really um you know pushing forward
with bitcoin and miami coin and all these sorts
of things um is what drove me here um so you know
i'm now adding value to this economy rather than
the london economy right among other things many
other things um freedom and many other things but
you know just on a small scale that's it simply
playing out so if places refuse to innovate
the innovators will leave um and so i yeah i agree
with you you know that's that's one of the major
concerns i mean i think the thing you bring is
excitement and opportunity uh to our shore and
uh the confidence we need confidence that uh it's
just like the way i think about the future there
are a lot of people that are worried about the
future and i am very robust i think number one
there's no problem that we can't solve and number
two i want to run at the future knowing we've got
good answers and good answers come from smart
people i like to say i'm not trying to be this way
so much but texans have the answers and i think
texas well we do we we look why why why are people
fleeing to texas there you go why are they
coming here well it's not because we got bad
ideas it's because we've been able to harness that
opportunity with the the affection that you spoke
about so i i look i understand why you're going
to miami as opposed to waco texas i get that uh
but but we've got i'll come say hi and well there
you go and florida has it i mean ron desantis as
as the young governor uh has really stepped up
and of course the the mayor uh there in miami
wants miami to be the the bitcoin capital of the
world uh good for them i like it i've sent some uh
some healthy some healthy state competition that
i can expect competition as you think there is
but we'll let you live there and we'll let you
enjoy great beach there absolutely you mentioned
um at the beginning of the conversation about the
um the lack of stability right now um with the
dollar so i'd like to just go into what are the
biggest problems facing the us dollar right now
well the biggest problem is inflation the biggest
problem is excessive government spending and the
bottom line which is undeniable and is that our
friends the democrats have made friends with the
things that create push and add to inflation and
and that's their go-to guy that is what they have
chosen uh overwhelmingly to do and they're not
wanting to back off that when you do things that
create circumstances to where either you put money
in that somebody else's money or you borrow money
to make up for your own deficiencies you are going
to then get away from that market that ability so
in this case uh there's a guy named joe biden
sleepy joe the president gets into office and
immediately goes to his fed chairman his treasury
chairman janet yellen and they put a demand on
for the federal government to begin issuing loans
bonds for 110 billion dollars a month and what
that does is it does at least two things that have
created the third and number one it it changes
uh who's paying money in and it became the federal
government the federal government took that lead
in authority and responsibility but you've got
to pay it back and so by taking out these loans
it means that our debt load is increased
greatly so if you think of america's green our
fed uh as like a great big bucket
of green paint green for money
value investment opportunity savings and
and then you pour a bunch of loans into it
let's be like throwing a different color
paint in i don't know what is white or purple
it changes the green to a different color
and that is what they're doing they and we
call that devaluation of the dollar so what is
happening is is that in order to float our boat
to meet the political considerations that our
friends the democrats wanted they didn't want
people to go to work even today even today
let's call this we'll act like today is 4 15
i know we're a day or two past that but april 15th
even april 15th the office of personnel management
out of the white house has not given instructions
for federal employees and agencies to get people
back to work if you look at their faq frequently
asked questions the questions and answers all
come from a year and a half ago when president
trump was in office and i assume there is some
relationship here these cats don't even under
biden don't even want to come to work themselves
they want to don't want to do work and
yet they want to be paid and our economy
which we are a capitalist nation i hope the
economy has to have people that go to work that
pay taxes that move our economy and democrats once
again they're very expensive the group of people
that are very expensive they're very snobbish
they want to take your money out of your pocket
out of your future out of your opportunity
and had you pay it to your favorite uncle
and so what's happened is is that uncle sam
now has taken this money and borrowed it
but we have to pay it back so the the biggest
problem that we've got is inflation now it's also
that democrats want people to stay at home they
want teachers not to be in the classroom without
our teachers in the classroom parents cannot
go to work you can't schedule yourself we have
blockchain issues literally i'm going to use that
term in the free enterprise system right now where
people cannot aren't going to work and so huge
just in time delivery systems whether it be
pipes or hoses or cars or food all these things
are being put in a way that is delayed so there
is a scarcity of of assets and resources out there
when there's a scarcity but people still need it
the highest bidder then pays the most for it
and that is what's causing inflation to go up
so once again perfect storm for the democrats
and president biden but like anything else
get ready because november is the election and
republicans are going to be able to i think sell
properly to the american people of what is
happening this is a grab for not just their
wallet this is a grab for changing america the
way we look and they want us to be socialist
and about half those cats wants to be they want
us to be a communist nation i still love to say to
them please show me where it works better in the
united states and their argument is very plainly
well it doesn't work very well well it may not
work very well but it works better than anywhere
else and i'm proud to be not only a texan i'm
proud to be for the free enterprise system
i'm a capitalist yeah i definitely agree with
you that um at this rate america is going
is going down a more socialist path i mean i've
had some conversations with um business owners
down here in miami and um people are saying
that they just can't get people back to work
um and they had that issue mainly during the
pandemic because people were literally getting
paid to stay at home um and so exactly right the
federal government is taking money and taking a
loan out for it and telling people ah don't
worry about it there's there's going to be
heck to pl to pay and that heck is what is
a it's it's a technical term but it it is uh
a recession yeah and um you mentioned the election
in november you previously uh previously tweeted
um that bitcoin is aligned with american
values so what are these american values
um that you think bitcoin is aligned with
and obviously how do you see that alignment
well very plainly the most obvious thing is
is that we want people to have freedom and
opportunity and to plan for their own future the
entire blockchain invention is innovative it is
creative and until proven otherwise safe so i want
america and americans just like yourself i mean
you're the one that wanted to come here probably
we didn't even invite you we should but you see
where there's opportunity and that opportunity
will lead to a lifestyle and an opportunity for
you to bring also the things which you believe are
right now this is where we kind of got into this
earlier about well is there kind of dangerous
that all these people are coming to texas
coming from california they're going to have to
understand there's no place after this to move
you just can't embed your government and give
them the authority or responsibility just to spend
like drunken sailors you've got to work within
the best interest of people and so i i think
we're going to do that the best part about this
is opportunity america needs to own the future
as we have the past for a long time and americans
have the creativity the objectivity and i am very
proud of bitcoin people because they have come
with a balance they care about health care they
care about disabled people they care about uh
giving back to their community we want them to
do that with their own wealth too so and so let's
focus on bitcoin i really want to understand what
is it specifically about the technology that you
like and you think would add value to america
well it is once again an opportunity for
people to own their own piece of the rock
it's an opportunity for them to know that the they
can go online they can see the relative value of
the the success of the currency it is not easy to
see that as a matter of fact we tend to go even
though we've seen some output uh in in the stock
market it is hard to see the dollar and the dollar
is what we're talking about so every time you if
you do want to look up and look at it you realize
it's getting rocked it's we're taking advantage of
it we're borrowing too much of it it's stability
is in question uh there's competition around the
world uh whether we are creating more wealth or
not whether the government is worried about that
soul factor too i mean the government is taking
advantage of us the democrats are are causing our
own demise so look it's easy to see if you can get
a stable necessarily a stable system where you can
have better control by looking at it on your phone
powerful so there's some concern um amongst
people in this community amongst bitcoin is that
politicians will say that they're pro bitcoin for
votes right um and this is something that people
are concerned with and we've seen politicians um
i hate to use the term but it sort of seems the
only way to sort of put it out there sort of come
out as pro bitcoin right um and then later on um
say that they are against bitcoin mining
so i don't like to name names but this is
something very concerning that that we've seen
mainly from democrat democrat mayors um so what
would you say to people who may be concerned that
perhaps you know you're just trying to win votes
um what would you say to them
to sort of ease their concerns
well first of all i'm not a democrat yeah there
you go and it and it is true it is true that
that the other party the socialist party
have been taken over by a large faction
that many of them actually see what they
believe is the same problem with the world
and that is what might be uh this energy issue
the uh the chance to to hate oil companies a
chance to want to go green with everything a
chance to spoil and and and change what might be
well-established uh paradigms uh of of money
and opportunity to fear well we had this one
of my problems is i remember a guy named jimmy
carter jimmy carter had everybody fear he's a
fear-mongerer we have long lines uh all across
america in the in the globe and he just fed that
to where you know when not only did we get
ronald reagan but we started learning more about
are we really running out of energy are we
afraid of our future is there not something
that we can use time and technology and and
ingenuity right now today there is more online
we know this more natural gas than we've ever had
and that's because of not just discoveries but
that is because of of a demand that we have and
so america is the saudia saudi arabia of of this
very important asset net gas natural gas and yet
lots of states and lots of territories and places
they won't go and even dig into this so look
it's money's going to be made there's going to
be opportunity we need a clean opportunity
we need an opportunity to have clean energy
i'm all for it but we we are headed that way
we're headed that way we're not only with
hydrogen but other opportunities and so i feel
very bullish about our ability to have a cleaner
environment moving forward but not putting us
all in bicycles which is what the democrats want
okay so let's go back to the democrats we've
seen um a video actually of um elizabeth warren
um refusing to understand that bitcoin um is not
good when it comes to um criminal activity um she
was sort of saying you know using non-custodial
wallets um it can essentially help enable illicit
activity and somebody was trying to explain to
her that actually that's not the case because
so on and so on and so on but she refused
to listen um which was quite sad and quite
shocking actually um just to refuse to to learn
something well why do you think that is so the
question is why do you think do you think it do
you think it's um uh an uh perhaps an age thing
do you think it's perhaps um you know done on
purpose why do you think certain people refuse to
understand bitcoin and therefore take actually um
a anti-bitcoin approach well i think it's from my
perspective who knows who's right that's a freedom
time kind of thing in the federal government
when controlled by democrats and the way
democrats operate they like to control
people they want to control activity they
want to control outcome uh not unusual but
literally every single bill we have in congress is
either more taxes more spending more regulations
or the reversal of that and then you
look up the other person that's behind it
oh it's a republican that wants more freedom
and opportunity see we know what we do works
we know that that's why there's more money
coming in the federal government than ever
when we cut taxes that's because we incented
people to go make it work and so look
god made at least two kinds of people
i want to be for freedom i want to be a
republican i want to live in texas and they they
literally are they think we're absurd here but
let people make their own decision i think i
know the right answer and i know where i am
so you're clearly very bullish on bitcoin where
do you see bitcoins um place in american society
well i see it's increasingly over the future i
think the future uh i i i'm for our country i
don't want to see our demise but you just cannot
take on the tremendous load of spending that we
have and and death and and you you can't do it
your own life and our country cannot do this
and have a brighter future so as long as we have
democrats that are in control and whether they're
running our cities or whether they're running our
states or whether running our federal government
they will bankrupt us they will cause inflation to
be outrageously uh uh powerful to where it steals
and robs our future and this is where if you
save money if you put money in and build on that
you can over time make a difference in everybody's
life and there's there's a dark side to this
big spending and democrats are perfectly happy
with it they the the chairman of the house budget
committee argued that it doesn't matter how much
money you spend or how what you do it deficits do
not harm anyone and he encouraged it by
the way he's not running for reelection now
but do you see bitcoin as a store
of value do you see it becoming
a medium of exchange do you see um do you see it
becoming the world reserve currency do you see it
replacing the us dollar like specifically where
do you see bitcoin's role in american society
well i see bitcoin's role in american
society is as a opportunity to watch it grow
and for us to learn i i am not for replacing the
dollar i'm just not i think there's enough room
to build value to where someone else can have what
they want need also but in the scheme of things
uh bitcoin as tremendously successful as they are
the the reserves of this country are in the dollar
they're in the the the backing of not just the
federal government they're in the backing of
business and so over time over time i i i'm not
going to be a naysayer and say it'll never happen
but i don't think it's in america's best interest
to get away from the the dollar being bullish
as the main currency when we start deb using
other people's currency we're in trouble
so you see as a store of value then as
something which could potentially replace gold
i think it's competitive i think it's very
competitive against gold gold is that standard
bearer that uh you know is ahead what's seen as
a hedge against inflation but there are a lot
of things that have got to happen and one of them
is this regulatory scheme that we talk about the
regulatory scheme of what are people going to
think about it what does government think about
it and as as you know there have been decisions
where uh bitcoin cannot be used for uh an ira
uh you also hear stories about how lots
of employees want their company to begin
giving their pay check or at least their bonus
uh in bitcoin because they want to use that
i think that to say that bitcoin uh and it's
just truthful unless you've bought in lately
virtually everything you've got is a
capital gain and when you go to spend money
and every time you produce a probably a vast
amount of taxation off your use of money
that that's difficult and so that it as it as
time moves on as it as there's less necessarily
uh uh volatility then then it could become but
i think there will be other things that come in
and work uh well with bitcoin uh cryptocurrency as
we know it but right now it's very obvious to me
that it it is a it's a high dollar play
it's a i take my bitcoin i go by my uh
sh my chevy tahoe i go buy my uh big big chevy
truck and i used that that was savings that i had
but uh on a basis of using it to buy
your uh your lone star beer or to go
purchase what might be uh your uh your weekly food
that that is gonna take a little bit of time uh
because you don't want to pay tax on that
you use it as an investment model as my point
yeah no i totally understand um it's been really
interesting just hearing your perspective on
bitcoin and you know how you see how you see
it playing out um especially in times of the
politicization um between you know the democrats
and and the republicans the unfortunate um
i'm on the side we need to let it grow i need to
see what it can become and and i i think there's
a lot of exuberance about it uh caution yeah sure
there's cost there's costing put the money in the
stock market there's caution about that too
but i i think that that it it finds its own
footing over time but without any question
entrepreneurship also will build value with
goods and services with things that people do buy
and make money with uh and it'll be in that system
yeah it's been really fascinating so do you
have any final comments you'd like to make
where can people um you know follow you support
you keep up with everything that you're doing
yeah i would say that i'm pete sessions
a member of congress from texas the 17th
congressional district they can look me up and
find me sessions.house.gov sessions.house.gov
comments i'm on instagram i'm on you know
all this i don't know about all but the
major social media platforms uh if they'd like to
come and engage me if they told me hey
look pete we're interested in bitcoin
uh and cryptocurrency and i'd please stay up with
us they can go on my website sessions.house.gov
there's a place where they can go and register
themselves and tell me what they're interested
in uh we talk about it we study it we're
trying to be victors for it we want to see it
do the right thing and and i think over time we're
going to be there congressman pete sessions thank
you so much i really appreciate your time it's
really important to have that transparency between
voters electorates and obviously politicians and
particularly when it comes to these new hot topics
so i want to thank you so much for hanging out now
now this weekend are you gonna go to nikki beach
uh no probably not i prefer to be by
myself listening to music and zoning out
let me tell you what if you want to be by
yourself nikki beach is not the place to be mike
has a great place there but it's your
closest hundred friends but it is a
topic of conversation in nikki beach is a very
exciting place for for young women like you to
uh to rub elbows with people for better
ideas and let's make america great again
maybe i'll have to check out nikki
beach then i'll let you know how it goes
okay good all right thanks so much and thank you
everyone for watching if you enjoyed this episode
please don't forget to hit the subscribe
button and we will see you next week bye